Did you know 92% of women with clogged lymphatic systems
are totally unaware of it?
Your lymphatic system is your body's
internal drainage network.
It runs through your entire body, your face, your neck,
your belly, your legs, and its entire job
is to flush out what your body no longer needs.
Dead cells, hormones, toxins, metabolic waste,
inflammatory proteins, all of it gets collected
and drained out.
When it's working, your body stays lean, clear, and fluid.
When it gets clogged, and it clogs more than most people
realize that waste has nowhere to go.
So it pools.
In your face, as morning puffiness that won't go away.
In your jaw, as softness that wasn't there a few years ago.
In your stomach, as bloating that shows up
even on your cleanest eating days.
In your legs, as heaviness and swelling
that builds throughout the day.
And here's where most women get it wrong.
They call it cellulite.
They call it water retention.
They call it edema.
They call it stubborn fat.
They go on diets, book lymphatic massages, drink more water,
try compression socks because nobody told them
what was actually happening.
It's not fat.
It's not aging.
It's backed up lymphatic waste that your body has
been trying to drain for months, maybe years, and can't.
And cutting calories doesn't drain it.
Exercise moves it temporarily, but doesn't dissolve it.
External massage pushes it around,
but can't reach what's hardened deep in your tissues.
The only way to clear it is from the inside.
Thymoquinone, the active compound in black seed oil,
supports a healthy inflammatory response
so your lymph can finally do its job again.
And here's what most women don't know.
More than 60% of your lymphatic tissue lives in your gut.
When the bacteria in your gut are out of balance,
your lymph backs up right where it
should be running the cleanest.
Carvacrol, the active compound in oregano oil,
supports a healthy gut microbial balance
and crowds out the bad bacteria so the gut lymph connection
runs clean again.
That's the formula inside Resilia.
Two soft gals every morning, the right doses
of both compounds in one capsule.
Week two, the face puffiness starts lifting.
The jaw definition comes back.
The leg heaviness drops.
Week four, the belly flattens.
The bloat clears.
And women realized what they'd been calling fat
or cellulite for years was actually something
their body simply never had the tools to handle.
Most supplements on Amazon only have one of these oils,
not both, and the ones that do have both
barely have any thymoquinone or carvacrol in them.
Resilia formulates both at the right doses in one soft gel.
If you want to try it, the link is below.
Resilia is up to 70% off right now
with a 30-day money-back guarantee.
Grab the deal while it's still running.